لقد اتخذ شعب الولايات المتحدة
خيارهم وبالطبع أنا
أقبل هذا القرار
ولكن علي أن أعترف ليس بنفس
الحماس الذي قبلت بالقرار
قبل أربع سنوات الذي
تحدثه الناس ونحن
نحترم عظمة النظام الديمقراطي أنا
فقط  اتصلت
بالحاكم كلينتون في موسيقى الروك الصغيرة
وقدم تهنئتي
لأنه أدار حملة قوية وأتمنى له
التوفيق في البيت الأبيض ،
وأعلم أن العديد من مؤيديي يشعرون
بخيبة أمل ،
لكن خيبة أملنا يجب التغلب
عليها بحبنا للوطن.
جميع الأمريكيين الذين دعموني
للانضمام إلي وليس فقط تهنئته
ولكن تقديم رئيسنا القادم حسن نيتنا
وجهودنا الجادة لإيجاد طرق
للالتقاء الليلة الماضية
هنأت دونالد ترامب
وعرضت العمل معه
نيابة عن بلدنا وآمل
ذلك  سيكون رئيسًا ناجحًا
لجميع الأمريكيين ، هذه ليست
النتيجة التي أردناها أو عملنا بجد من
أجلها وأنا آسف لأننا لم نفز بهذا الانتخاب.
للقيم التي نتشاركها والرؤية
التي نتمسك
بها لبلدنا